[inaudible]
almost 50 years ago in 1969 then
president Richard Nixon announced the so
called war on drugs.
It's a hard line strategy that aims to
pursue and punish the production,
distribution and consumption of
substances that were considered
prohibited drugs.
America's public enemy number one in the
United States is drug abuse.
Since then is if you,
even though Washington has used all his
mind to this hotline strategy as a
result of is in a resounding failure
both at home and abroad.
See,
each year the u s government spends tens
of billions of dollars in this
particular war,
achieving practically nothing more than
imprisoning hundreds of thousands of
people and fueling a culture of
violence.
The war on drugs has been going on for
60 years,
and if a business,
if I'd had a business that had failed
for 60 years,
I would have closed it down 59 years
ago.
The federal government's figures on
arrests for violence.
NC drug laws are absolutely
schilling
for the shoulder.
Every year the United States authorities
rest more than 1 million people for
breaking anti drug laws.
That is to say in 10 years,
the United States,
the rest as many people as the entire
population of Greece or Cuba for drug
related crimes,
which is well,
a lot of
people since
1989 ans listen carefully because this
is rather impressive in the United
States,
more people have been imprisoned for
this type of crime than for all other
violent crimes combined.
Our most serious problem today is
cocaine and in particular crap.
Who's responsible?
Let me pet you straight out.
Everyone who uses drugs,
everyone who sells drugs and everyone
who looks the other way.
In fact,
this is precisely what has led the
country to have the highest
incarceration rate in the wells four or
five times higher than other countries
like France or Germany and even higher
than totalitarian countries like China.
It's all pretty damn crazy as of course,
as you can imagine,
US jails aren't exactly the best place
in the world to rehabilitate.
In fact,
the American experience seems to say
quite the opposite,
but all right,
you might be thinking,
okay,
Simon,
it might be a tough strategy,
but maybe it's fulfilling its purpose,
right?
Well,
the truth is that no,
it isn't beyond crowding prison spending
hundreds of billions and condemning many
young people do have difficulties of
reentering the world with a criminal
record.
This war on drugs as achieved very,
very little.
In fact,
it's achieved practically nothing.
despite so many efforts,
the United States still has one of the
highest drug use rates in the world.
This rate is even higher today than it
was in the 1980s we lost more than 175
to overdoses every day,
and millions more are struggling with
addiction
and regarding their results outside of
the United States.
What?
What can I say?
We only need to take a look at Latin
America to see how that's gone because
my friends,
there was one thing this war on drugs
has certainly achieved,
and that's helping drug traffickers make
a lot of money.
Yup.
You heard that right?
Yeah.
Entire pro edition and strong anti
strategy.
I've made the illegal drug trade
extremely lucrative.
Basically a goldmine,
which is pouring money into drug
traffickers,
gangs and cartels,
while spreading violence throughout
Latin America.
Yeah.
Cocaine cartel does not begin in Meti
and Columbia.
It begins in the streets of New York,
Miami,
Los Angeles and every American city were
crack is bought and sold.
Nancy Reagan
and drug dealers need to know that we
want them out of high schools,
neighborhoods and our lives and the only
way to do that is to take the customers
away from the product,
say no to drugs and say yes to life.
That holds your horse is just a moment
because often many failures it seems a
new strategy isn't being pursued in the
United States and so far,
well the results have been quite
promising.
You might have heard about the changes
in the marijuana industry
with these scissors.
I dubbed the Bri
big change
on January the first 2018 California
became the eighth territory in the
United States to legalize the
production,
distribution and consumption of
marijuana for recreational use.
It's a medical use was approved way back
in 1996
wow,
thanks.
Is this in addition to California and
Alaska,
Colorado,
Oregon,
Massachusetts,
Maine,
Washington,
Nevada,
ans the capital of Washington DC.
Marijuana is recreational use is
perfectly legal for its paws.
The state of Vermont has just announced
that starting on July the first
possession and consumption will also be
legal.
Okay.
As we're talking about a very,
very important change,
especially if you take into account so
that federal legislation as we'll see
later,
still considers this a prohibited
activity.
Well,
last year this new marijuana industry
legally moved almost a $7 billion,
a figure that is expected to rise
strongly in the upcoming years,
especially since the California market
alone is estimated to make more than $5
billion.
We're talking about an industry that is
already generating many jobs and also
paying loads of tax and we're not only
talking about selling marijuana for
direct consumption.
A lot of new businesses are also
emerging,
which take advantage of its ingredients,
candy,
cookies,
sweets.
We have hundreds of products.
This business is worth a lot and the
state keeps 25% of every dollar we make.
Eric Kinney,
owner of Zen,
West Hollywood,
a marijuana dispensary in Los Angeles.
Understand to believe the states that
have legalized this industry have also
set special regulations and taxes for
it.
Okay.
Cities and counties have basically done
the same thing,
regulation state,
how it can be sold,
where it can be sold,
and how much has to be paid for it.
It's like any other heavily regulated
industry.
Look at the pharmaceutical industry or
the liquor industry.
They're heavily,
heavily regulated industries and the
cannabis industry is no different.
Cara Martinson,
Federal Affairs Manager for the
California State Association of
counties,
and this is not exactly cheap for these
companies.
In some California in cities,
the sum of all taxes can amounts to 40%
of these new companies turnover,
which is a lot in Colorado.
The first dates there's a legalized the
sale and consumption of marijuana for
recreational use,
the industry already invoices about $1
billion every year and to the state's
income in taxes exceed $200 million.
Among the eight states where
recreational marijuana is legal only
Washington as a higher tax rate at about
50% Colorado and Nevada both follow with
rates of 36% Oregon has a tax of 20% and
Alaska has a rate of up to 20% Aaron
Smith,
a CNN reporter,
however you had to wait a minutes
because everything doesn't end here.
Let's just say that there's a problem.
I'm very serious problem,
in fact,
as I said before,
federal us,
nor continues to consider this a
forbidden activity which makes this type
of business very difficult,
if not impossible when it comes to,
for example,
obtaining credits from the financial
institution.
Of course,
if a bank decides to finance these
companies activities,
they could even be accused of
collaborating with a drug trafficker and
not only that,
see until now a policy in stools by the
Obama Administration was in force,
which led to the Justice Department
asking federal prosecutors not to file
charges if the drug's production sale
and consumption with legal based on
state laws.
Well,
this policy known as the Cole memo was
suspended by Jeff sessions.
Donald trump's appointed attorney
general.
This drug is dangerous.
You cannot play with it.
It's not funny.
It's not something to laugh about and
and trying to send that message with
clarity that good people don't smoke
marijuana.
The prosecutor has announced that he
wants to prosecute marijuana businesses,
which by the way,
trump promised he wouldn't do during his
campaign.
But I think in terms of marijuana,
I think,
and legalization,
I think that should be a state issue
state.
This is why this entirely new industry
is now submerged in a sea of
uncertainty.
Will be attorney general,
fulfill his wishes.
Will the trump administration attack the
marijuana industry?
These are the questions on the table,
but well,
only the future can answer for now
though.
We can discuss why this change in
approach could be a huge,
I'm of changes a few years since
Colorado became the first states in 2014
to legalize the recreational use of
marijuana.
Just as we've seen in this video,
a few more states have joined since
then,
so we can now analyze what's happens and
we can look at this policy's
consequences.
The time legalization critic stated that
the risks of allowing the recreational
use of cannabis were really high.
For example,
they said consumption among miners would
probably increase as would crime and
traffic accidents.
Well,
now we can see what actually happens and
it's not just the truth is nothing like
these catastrophic predictions.
Neither violence nor consumption among
miners and our traffic accidents have
increased.
In fact,
legalization has had very positive
consequences
on the one hand and the quality of the
product sold on the black market has
increased in consumption of more
dangerous substances has actually
decreased in the states.
Legalization of marijuana for
recreational use has given us consumers
access to high quality marijuana.
We genetically improve strains,
groaning,
greenhouses or rule beneath does manawat
a drug war expert at Mexico's National
Autonomous University and keep listening
here because this is really important.
A few years ago,
the Cato Institute published a study
that determines that eight out of 10
deaths caused by drugs.
What do you to the product?
Poor quality.
This is a major social problem,
so consumption except for medicine we'll
use is never good.
That certainly clear,
but there's still the demands,
which is why improving the product
quality and safety reduces or potential
damage,
but there's more hair
legalization is reducing as logical the
cartels business and therefore the money
that these groups receive.
In addition,
and this is perhaps its most important
effects,
it has allowed a marijuana trafficking
related arrests do drop,
which has had two very clear
consequences for one security forces and
courts have been able to allocate more
resources to fighting serious crime and
for another it has reduced the number of
people in prison for victimless crimes
like marijuana consumption.
We could say that in the states that
opted for legalization,
the culture of violence,
which is a serious problem in the United
States has decreased.
And if that one's enough,
legalization means that the governments
can now collect taxes from this
industry.
So if the United States wants to
decrease its high consumption rates,
it looks like a legalizing marijuana,
maybe a really good idea.
Legalization sheds light on a business
that has been in the shadows until now,
while allowing for a safer and better
controlled products.
On top of that,
the authorities get allocate the money
obtained through this industry's taxes
to carry out awareness and health
campaigns.
It's something that my the way was very
successful in Portugal,
but that's something we're going to talk
about in another video.
The fact is maybe due to all of this
polls showed that more than 60% of
Americans favor legalization.
More states are continuing to announce
their intention to legalize marijuana,
not only for medical use but also for
recreational.
This is certainly something that's
becoming a trend.
In 2013 year ago,
I became the first country in the world
to legalize the production,
distribution and consumption of
marijuana.
Although it is highly regulated that in
the year 2018 everything indicates the
Canada is going to follow in his
footsteps.
At least that's what Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau has promised.
The reason we are choosing to legalize
control marijuana is because the current
system is not protecting our kids.
It's right now easier for a an underage
Canadian,
the teenager to buy a joint,
uh,
than it is for them to get their hands
on a bottle of beer.
By the way,
just as an extra hit about 80 cannabis
related companies are listed on the
Canadian Stock Exchange and in 2017 they
revalued by no less than 250% not bad.
Right.
It seems like a new industry is
developing a new industry in which among
others the well known investor,
Peter Thiel,
who we already talked about here on
visual politic is betting strongly
namely through the Canadian company
privateer holdings,
which is setting up the largest
marijuana plantation in Europe,
in Portugal.
Anyways,
you have your,
that's the way things are,
but now it's your turn.
Do you support the legalization of
marijuana?
Will leave us your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this
video.
If you did these do hit that thumbs up
button and do not forget to subscribe to
our channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and to also don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you.
Cheng,
America's public enemy number one in the
United States is drug abuse.